Russian president of Vladimir Putin has
declared martial law in the four regions
of Ukraine that Moscow has illegally
annexed just weeks ago
Putin made the announcement in a
televised statement to members of his
Security Council the decree hands more
powers to local officials in the
occupied regions Russian installed
officials in her song one of the four
occupied regions called for Mass
civilian evacuations in the face of
advancing Ukrainian forces
now let's hear some more of what Mr
Putin had to say
let me remind you that martial law was
in effect in the Donetsk People's
Republic the luhansk People's Republic
in the Herson and zaparisia regions ever
since their entry into the territory of
Russia and now it is therefore necessary
to apply this law within the Russian
legal framework therefore I have signed
a decree on the introduction of Martial
law in these four regions of the Russian
Federation
now officials installed by the Kremlin
in the Carson region have announced a
large-scale evacuations of civilians
they expect a Ukrainian offensive
Russian forces are struggling to
maintain their hold on several strategic
positions in regions that they they were
annexed in the east and south the
commander of Russian troops in Ukraine
has been forced to acknowledge
difficulties
a fierce battle for control over her
song looms again it was one of the first
Ukrainian cities to fall to Russian
forces at the start of the war
now Russia says Ukraine is preparing to
take it back
images posted on social media by a
Russian installed official claimed to
show fortifications outside the city
Pro Kremlin Regional leaders are urging
civilians to leave in order to avoid
casualties and to give the Russian army
room to maneuver
I ask you to interpret my word seriously
as a call to evacuate quickly we won't
abandon the city we'll stand Until the
End
since issuing the evacuation order the
russian-appointed administration said it
had decided to move across the NEPA
River but vowed that moscow's forces
would fight to the death
keeping her son will be the first big
test for General Sergey surovicin in his
new role as commander of Russia's forces
in Ukraine
The Man known as general Armageddon
admitted the battle for Hassan would not
be easy
further actions and plans regarding the
city of Cresson itself will depend on
the military tactical situation at hand
I will say this again it is already very
difficult as of today
as for the tens of thousands of people
Moscow says are fleeing the city Russia
has promised them housing certificates
if they wish to leave Ukraine
but it's unclear how many are leaving
under their own free will
since the start of the invasion Kiev has
accused Moscow of forcibly resettling
thousands of ukrainians to territories
inside Russia far from home
and for more let's bring in our
correspondent in akiv Matias Matthias
Putin has declared martial law in
Ukrainian territories that Russia
illegally annexed what does that now
mean in Practical terms
in Practical terms it's hard to say
formally these decrees give the military
Administration more powers and they give
them additional powers to for example
restrict movements of civilians but also
to forcibly evacuate people from uh
areas
um the thing is that these territories
have been occupied and this was not a
rule of law so anyway the
administration's already exercised a lot
of powers that they did not have because
no law was basically applicable to their
Administration
but it formalizes the the power of these
military administrations in these areas
and of course it's another
gesture by the Kremlin trying to assert
control and trying to assert formal
control over these territories after the
annexations that have happened if few
weeks ago now Matthias there have been
reports of explosions in Keith during
the past a couple of hours what can you
tell us
the air defenses have shut down several
missiles over the city that's what we
heard there was another attack this
afternoon with missiles and drones
launched on Ukrainian territory
um besides Kiev also other places were
attacked again power stations in the
central parts of the country and they
were also in the north east or from from
here into nihif there were also attacks
on infrastructure and civilian
infrastructure there
now Pro Kremlin authorities in Carson
are said to be evacuating ahead of an
expected Ukrainian offensive they're
also called on residents to get out what
more can you tell us about these
evacuations
you don't know many details but what the
authorities have said is that they
expect attacks from the Ukrainian side
they expect uh Ukraine pushing into
these regions
um the administration is is said to have
left the city of Kirsten so they might
expect either fights there or they might
even uh consider leaving these uh
retreating from these areas and they
have called on people to leave they've
also said they would evacuate people
from there and these decrees from today
give them the formal power to also
forcibly evacuate people from there
there's of course the fear that this
means deportations may be into Russia
forced deportations from occupied
regions are considered war crimes and
international law
TW Smarties building there reporting
from Keith thank you Matthias
and we can now speak to yes
she's a news editor and presenter of TV
rain that's one of the last independent
news networks in Russia that was shut
down she's now working from abroad
Katarina President Putin imposing
martial law there in the annex
territories we've just heard about it
what's your take on this
well this is something that brings us
very close to the moment when the
president of Russian Federation and and
his employees including the
representatives of Russian government
would be forced to name this situation a
war because so far there were insisting
on the special military operation
so-called special needs operation not
acknowledging not telling Russians that
this is actually a war going on not only
in Ukraine but also on the parts of
Russian Federation On the Border there
are right now right now serious
situations in bilgarotsky region for
example we can see that the shellings
missiles are on the ground right now
these days and during during the months
uh this last month so people are scared
to death in Russia after the so-called
partial mobilization that Putin has
declared after this martial law people
that he has adopted a couple of hours
ago it's becoming closer and closer to
Russians and you know we are so used to
this uh narrative that Russians do not
care about what's going on in Ukraine
about the death of civilians about
atrocities so right now even those who
really did not care I'm insisting that
they're not majority but of course there
were people who did not care about
what's going on because they were
comfortable in their own lives so even
these people now are acknowledging their
understanding that this war is coming to
their homes and this is a very important
moment right now even the uh Russian
command of the new Russian commander in
Ukraine zorovicin has said that things
are difficult in the occupied region
does this admission come as a surprise
to you
of course because uh before Surah vikin
the representatives of Ministry of
Defense of Russia there were repeating
on and on this uh words about uh about
the victory about the plan which is
being completed about everything is all
right and so on and so forth right now
pseudo vegan uh is uh presented by
Vladimir Putin by Kremlin as the person
who comes with a new approach and I was
astonished yesterday I can honestly say
when I when I was reading the telegram
channels of Russian propaganda faces uh
saying the same thing about surovicin
that this is the guy who is open with us
who is fair and honest with us this is a
new approach of minister of defense and
he is becoming a hero a symbol of new
stage of the so-called special military
operation and they really hope that you
know admitting the problems will bring
eventually Russia to the big victory and
Ukraine and occupation not only of this
annexed territories but also of Kiev and
and wolf and other parts of Ukraine so
this is something and he is someone who
they think can bring maybe even hope for
those Russians who are scared as I said
and those Russians who don't want to be
part of this war who are running away
from the country from this mobilization
that they they think that maybe
surovicin would be the guy who would let
the the people so people people are
running away people are scared in in
Russia so how damaging have these recent
setbacks been for Putin's Authority
I am pretty sure honestly saying that
this whole war was a great mistake of
Vladimir Putin and every new Step that
he takes makes the situation worse
um this mobilization this martial law uh
all the problems that Russian regions
Russian regions
um are going through right now uh you
know it all brings Vladimir Putin to a
very tough
um choice that he will need to make I
mean he's not gonna surrender obviously
he's not gonna say all right guys it was
my mistake I'm going from Ukraine I'm
leaving Ukraine I don't want this
anymore it's impossible to imagine so
every single step that he will take
after that would be even worse and worse
I'm really scared of
um using a technical nuclear weapon
which is uh kind of a you know one one
of the one of the plans that they are
considering in crime then so uh this is
the this is the beginning of the end for
Vladimir Putin the only one question is
what he will be able to accomplish and
how many people will die before before
the end
a news editor and presenter the
independent Russian TV station rain
thank you very much for joining us here
on DW news my pleasure